so
even today in the age of the hydrogen
bomb and supersonic flight
much of africa remains wild in primeval
in many parts of the continent wild
animals such as the elephant
giraffe hippopotamus and others still
abound
over large areas man still is a
primitive existence in much the same way
as did his forebears
civilization has left little imprint
upon him
and he still carries on his daily
occupations in accordance with his
ancient customs
in vast areas in africa there are
countless persons suffering from many
strange and exotic diseases
some of which are found nowhere else in
the world some of these diseases are
swift killers
while others leave their victims
permanently incapacitated
until death finally intervened
these diseases greatly interfere with
the economic development of the tropical
countries
and hamper the exportation of enormous
reservoirs of material resources so much
needed by the free world
furthermore there's a constant threat of
the spread beyond the tropics by means
of today's
rapid transportation systems
research in the field of tropical
medicine is of more than academic or
altruistic
concern to the people of the united
states because our own economy is
involved
sixty percent of our imports come from
the tropical countries
including many of the strategic
materials which we lack
before one can hope to control or
eliminate these various diseases
it is necessary to study them in the
areas in which they are prevalent
to do this scientists must make their
way into the heart of the endemic areas
by whatever means are available
shown here is a national institute of
health research team
working as a part of the 0.4 program
leaving for a field survey in the
liberian hinterland
field investigations are especially
important in arriving at method for the
prevention and control of tropical
diseases
tropical medicine is not a static
science and the tropics cover vast areas
of the globe methods employed to combat
a particular disease in one part of the
tropics may not be equally applicable
elsewhere
all aspects of tropical medicine however
cannot be studied in the field
but must be investigated at special
research centers
not only in the tropics but also in the
more advanced areas where specialized
equipment and qualified personnel are
more readily available
this film will show how aspects of some
of the more important
tropical diseases of africa with special
reference to conditions in liberia west
africa
together with some of the research work
being done not only in that area
but also at the national institutes of
health of the united states public
health service
malaria is an acute recurring febrile
disease caused by protozoan parasites of
the genus plasmodium
which are transmitted by an undergo part
of their life cycle
in certain anathelein mosquitoes this
disease
is one of the main obstacles to
successful settlement in many warm
countries
the part it plays in general world
morbidity and mortality is hard to judge
but it is thought to be responsible for
more illness and death per year
than any other transmissible disease
the prevalence of malaria parasites in a
population group can best be ascertained
by means of microscopic examination
of thick blood smears while the
parasites are more abundant in the blood
of infants and children before the
development of immunity
it is not uncommon in hyperendemic areas
to demonstrate them in 80 to 90 percent
of adults examined
thick blood smears are used primarily in
surveys and for case findings because of
high concentration of parasites provided
by this technique
thin blood smears are more suitable when
exact species determination is required
or when morphological studies are
desired in order to gain a complete
picture of malaria in any region it is
necessary to study the mosquitoes that
transmit it
larvae and pupae of anaphylene
mosquitoes are sought in the field in
order to locate their breeding areas
and to study the conditions under which
they multiply
adult mosquitoes can be captured in
traps placed over windows of huts a
study of these mosquitoes will show
among other things which species are the
most important
in a given locality this is done by
demonstrating sporozoites the infective
stage of the malaria parasite in the
salivary glands of the mosquito
these glands are easily dissected from
the mosquito and when gently crushed
under the coverslip
the sporozoites are expelled and can be
readily seen under the microscope
only a small portion of the mosquitoes
captured are found infected
but in view of the vast numbers which
feed on unprotected individuals in the
tropics
even a small percentage of infected
mosquitoes is sufficient to maintain a
high incidence of infection
in the population the clinical diagnosis
of malaria
is frequently difficult it may be
confused with many diseases both
cosmopolitan and tropical
this is inevitable in view of the
pathology which consists mainly of
mechanical interference
with the vascular supply in many organs
of the body
among the tropical diseases with which
it may be confused
are calars are amoebic liver abscess
relapsing fever
and yellow fever among the cosmopolitan
diseases it may simulate typhoid fever
tuberculosis
brucellosis influenza violitis
and other septic conditions as well as
certain diseases
of the central nervous system great
strides have been made in recent years
in developing new drugs for the
suppression and treatment of malaria by
testing
thousands of compounds against the
malarias of lower animals
such as chicks the drug being tested
here is administered orally to the
infected chick
blood smears are prepared before and at
intervals after treatment
the anti-malarial effect of the compound
is then determined by the presence or
absence of the malaria parasite
an essential part of all research
concerns the publication of the results
shown here is a monograph in which data
on nearly 4 000 compounds are analyzed
to show the relationship between
chemical structure and anti-malarial
activity
the final evaluation of any
anti-malarial drug must of course be
made against human malaria in
endemic areas
anchor circiasis is a form of filariasis
transmitted by gnats of the genius
similium
the adult worms live in subcutaneous
nodules while the larvae or microfilaria
migrate within the layers of the skin
these microfilari frequently penetrate
into the structures of the eye so that a
variable proportion of the population in
the endemic area suffers from partial or
complete blindness
blindness due to this disease usually
affects less than one percent of the
population
however in scattered foci the incidence
may be extremely high
the subcutaneous nodules which contain
the coiled-up adult worms are the most
characteristic lesions of ankur
psychiasis
ocular changes usually occur only after
long and repeated exposure
these changes bear no relation to the
anatomic location of the nodules but
rather are associated
with the development of sensitivity to
antigenic substances
produced by the parasite or its product
the most widely distributed vector of
ankur psychiasis in africa
is the nat similium damnosum which
breeds in cataracts and waterfalls of
rapidly flowing streams where the larvae
and pupae may be found attached to
submerged stones
and vegetation the other principal
vector
is similar nivea which is found
primarily in east africa and parts of
the congo
it was only after years of diligent
search that the larvae and pupae of this
fly were found to live only on the
carapace and legs of a freshwater crab
potterman melodicus the discovery of the
ecology of the larval and pupil stages
of this net
has greatly simplified the control and
eradication
of anker psychiatrists in the areas in
which the millionaire is the sole vector
the simulates are daytime feeders which
have a painless bite and are not easily
disturbed after they have started
feeding
the incidence of infection in these
flies is determined by searching for
developing stages of the worm aqua circa
in nets
captured while feeding on natives
serving as human bait
the ingested larvae or microfilari leave
the stomach of the fly and penetrate the
thoracic muscles where they grow into
the so-called sausage stage
after six days or more of development
the elongated infective larvae
travel to the labium of the fly when the
insect bites another person the larvae
escape
and penetrate into the skin the
microfilaria live in the dermis of the
skin
and can be demonstrated easily in skin
biopsies which consist
of thin slices of skin placed in drops
of normal saline
this method is satisfactory only where
anka circa is the only third encountered
since microfilari which are
characteristically found in the blood
occasionally occur in skin biopsies
all species of microfilari can be
readily demonstrated and identified in
scarification smears which are prepared
by making several superficial incisions
in the skin
with a scalpel and squeezing out the
blood and tissue juices
this material can be examined fresh for
motile microfilari
but must be examined as a thick blood
smear stained with hematoxylin to
determine the species
butcher area bankruptcy microfilari have
a sheath and the nuclei extend farther
forward
than to those of the anka circle
volvulus which have a somewhat bulbous
head
and no sheath trypanosomiasis is an
acute and chronic disease produced by
protozoan parasites of the genus
trypanosoma american trypanosomiasis or
chagas disease is caused by
trypanosoma cruzi which is transmitted
by bugs of the genus
triatoma african trypanosomiasis or
sleeping sickness is caused by
trypanosoma gambianzi in the western and
equatorial parts of africa
and trypanosoma rodiciency in the
eastern part of the continent
both are transmitted by various species
of glossina or tetsy flies
it has been said that the economic
future of equatorial africa depends
largely upon the issue of the struggle
of science against the scourge of
trypanosome diseases
which affect both man and domestic
animals
the sleeping or somnolent stage of
gambian trypanosomiasis begins with
apathy associated with creamers
shuffling gait and incoordination from
which it proceeds to true coma
and eventually death the latter is
usually due to malnutrition
or intercurrent infection when the
tropanosomes are ingested
by this etsy fly they undergo a cyclical
development in the digestive tract
after 18 to 34 days infected
trypanosomes reach the salivary ducts
and enter the bright wound at the next
feeding
glossina palpailis the tessifly which
transmits gambian sleeping sickness
frequents the dense undergrowth
bordering watercourses the pregnant
female produces a single large fully
developed larva
at intervals of about 10 days the larva
burrows into the ground to a depth of
about two inches
and immediately pupates the pupa hatches
into an adult ply
in three to twelve weeks tetsy flies of
the glossino marsitan group which
transmit rhodesian sleeping sickness
are less dependent upon water and are
found in wooded savannah country
that provides moderate shade cover is
more or less essential
and suitable breeding grounds largely
determine the location of the fly belt
with drugs now available it is possible
to cure the majority of sleeping
sickness patients provided they are
treated before invasion of the central
nervous system by the parasite
all individuals in an endemic area are
examined for evidence of the disease
such as in large posterior cervical
lymph nodes
which is called winter bottom signs
and for the presence of the parasite in
blood smears
nodule aspiration is useful in
diagnosing the gambian form of the
disease
a study of the spinal fluid will
determine whether the central nervous
system is involved
an increase in the amount of protein or
in the cell count indicate such
involvement
in which event the patient must be
treated with one of the more toxic
arsenical compounds
such as triparsamide or arsibol due to
the rather ineffective methods of
diagnosing sleeping sickness
attempts are being made to develop tests
which will detect the disease in early
stages
fractions of protein derived from
trypanosomes are purified by various
procedures including dialysis
and then concentrated by evaporation and
lyophilization
drying is completed under vacuum while
the material is still frozen
the resulting product is then used in
various types
of serologic tests
information gleaned from basic research
on the physiology and metabolism of the
trypanosomes
contributes to knowledge of the
parasites and may lead to the
development of a drug that will destroy
them regardless of their location in the
human body
schistosomiasis a chronic disease caused
by blood flukes of the genius histosoma
is characterized by inflammatory and
proliferative
lesions of the liver genital urinary and
lower intestinal tracts
several species of schistosomes are
capable of infecting man but only three
are important clinically
schistosoma and sonar and the more
virulent schistosoma japonicum
primarily involve the intestinal tract
while schistosoma hematobium
affects the genito urinary tract
schistosomiasis is one of the most
widespread and serious of all the
diseases produced by animal parasites
the disease is estimated to affect 115
million people in the world and seems to
be spreading in the near eastern brazil
shown here is a district health clinic
in the liberian hinterlands staffed by a
u.s public health service position
under the foreign technical assistance
program
nearly half of the patients attending
this clinic have urinary systoliasis
symptoms of this infection are caused by
small ulcers in the bladder
and consist of hematuria burning on
urination
and suprapubic or peroneal pain the
prevalence of schistosomiasis varies
considerably from place to place even in
the same endemic area
and hence surveys are necessary to
evaluate its local importance
the ova of schistosoma hematobium in the
urine are concentrated by centrifugation
the supernatant is decanted and the
sediment
is examined under the microscope for the
eggs when the schistosome egg reaches
fresh water
a ciliated larva parmericidium is free
and must find and penetrate a suitable
snail host in order to continue the life
cycle
only a few species of snails are capable
of serving as intermediate host for the
schistosomes
in the snail the parasite undergoes a
two-phase process of development
ending in four to seven weeks with the
production of tens of thousands
of free swimming infective forms called
cercari
when an individual wades or works in
infested waters the organisms become
attached to the exposed skin and
penetrate within a few minutes
slow moving streams clogged with
vegetation and high organic content
are particularly favorable habitats for
the snails which transmit
schistosomiasis
in such advantageous surroundings these
snails frequently are
found in enormous numbers man himself
contributes to their welfare and to the
spread of the disease
when he disturbs natural conditions and
constructs new ponds
alters the course of streams or
introduces irrigation systems
colonies of snails that serve as vectors
of schistosomiasis in many parts of the
world are maintained at the national
institutes of health and are utilized in
research
on prevention and control of this
disease
the mollusca side effect of numerous
compounds has been determined in the
laboratory by mixing various
concentrations
of the substance being tested in small
aquarius
the vector snails are then added to the
treated water
and after a stated interval of time the
snails are removed and the lethal
action of the compound is determined by
noting the proportion of dead and live
snails
using this or similar techniques it has
been shown
that sodium pentaquarphonate is an
effective molluscicide
and numerous field tests have been made
with this compound
shown here is a report on an experiment
to compare the effect
of this chemical on different laboratory
strains of the same vector species
studies to determine the mechanism of
action of sodium pentaquarphonate
have been made on various species of
snails shown here is an experiment
in which a suspension of cells is
prepared by comminuting the liver
of a snail followed by differential
centrifugation
various concentrations of a molluscicide
are added to this
suspension and the effect on the
metabolism of the cell is observed these
studies
indicate that the molluscacidal property
of sodium
pentaclavinate is due at least in part
to its ability to inactivate certain
enzyme systems and thus prevent the cell
from utilizing the energy
available from the metabolic breakdown
of nutriment
comparative studies on the physiology
and metabolism of the same species of
vector snail from different geographical
areas
such as the anaerobic carbon dioxide
production experiment shown here
have demonstrated marked differences in
what appear to be identical snails
this helps to explain why snails in
different areas do not always react
similarly
to identical control measures the
schistosomicidal activity of numerous
drugs has been tested in mice
these animals have been infected by
inserting their tails into water
containing live circari
after the infection is developed the
mice are treated with the test compounds
and after suitable intervals are autopsy
to determine the schistosomicidal effect
of the drug
untreated mice or those treated with
ineffective compounds have adult worms
in the mesenteric and portal veins and
evidence of innumerable eggs in the
liver
mice treated with effective drugs have
few eggs in the liver and show remains
of dead worms in the liver tissue
furthermore all adult worms have
disappeared from the mesenteric and
portal veins
in this experiment antibiotic complexes
of antimony
trichloride were found to be active
orally against schistosoma mansoni
but no more active than plane antimony
trichloride or tartar hermetic
it is hoped that eventually an effective
and non-toxic drug will be found to aid
in the control
of what the world health organization
considers to be one of the world's most
important health problems
during the past half century great
strides have been made in our knowledge
of tropical diseases
however only a few of these diseases
have been adequately controlled
because of their public health and
economic importance they must be studied
more intensively both in the laboratory
and in the field if these maladies can
be further checked
and ultimately eradicated africa need no
longer be referred to as the dark
continent
equal benefits will redown to other
parts of the globe
where many of these scourges also take
their toll
you